dolcetto o scherzetto
a 1600 dove vai
risotto alla zucca
lasagna alla zucca
e
[Musica]
si certo
mi ricordo benissimo che mi devo vestire
per halloween
sì sì l'omesso
o no l'ho trovato subito costume per
halloween vado a cercare qualcosa
ecco il mio costume di halloween
si incrocia si sono prontissimo
per che cosa dite grave vito top per che
cosa servono le stive non si capisce
sono un chimico alimentare chimico
alimentare
assaggio tutti i cibi per vedere se sono
avvelenate o no ma lo sapevo che non
avrei dovuto lasciar scegliere evitare
il suo costume per halloween almeno
capisco cosa sono
[Musica]
ma sì certo se un bambino
sapessero papiro non pericolosi questo
guarda questo questo e questo sembra uno
stemma del lecce aspetta un idea metto
qua ora sarai d'altro canto lo trovo
esibita una strega
meno male finalmente si è arrivato
davvero
sicure sega
beh cambia il costume subito questa una
festa di halloween non di carnevale a me
piace questo questo travestimento è
quello che cos'è l'hai presa tu ti
guarda super divertente ti faccio vedere
come funziona che cos'è uno specchio si
è uno specchio guarda
senza questa cosa o violenze c'è perché
fatevi prendere questo specchio design
travestito diretta lei
guarda con te non funziona i bambini non
si possono vedere nello specchio
ha preso un altra cosa però si è finiti
per godersi lo spettacolo ok mi sono
seduta beh che cosa dovrei vedere adesso
proprio
[Musica]
è questa una zucca parlante e si è
proprio la zucca parlando devo dire che
super carina però parla in inglese ha
detto sai qual è la differenza tra me e
tutte le altre decorazioni di halloween
che io so se tu stai parlando di me devo
dire che questa zucca parlante anche i
microfoni ascolta beh ma tanto non
riuscirà a capire la nostra lingua no
effettivamente non lo so se capisce
anche l'italiano ma scritta ti facciamo
vedere anche le altre funzioni di questa
zucca
[Musica]
beh devo dire che è super carina canta
pure quindi forse ti perdono per il
fatto che non ti sei travestito per
halloween con un vero costume pauroso no
grazie ma di la verità volevi mangiare
anche quella di zucca o no no stavo solo
guardando le ricette alla zucca tanto
poi queste zucchero mangeremo ho come
l'impressione che se mangiamo queste
zucche si arrabbieranno i si
ribelleranno contro di noi vi ricordate
cosa è successo l'anno scorso le zucche
volanti quale zucchi arrabbiatissima e
dove stai guardando no non equa la zucca
parlare del ranger di
ecuador da vino
[Musica]
dicevano che c'è qua
a veroli non all'interessata che vecchia
risultato no non mi portare così non
solo il veterinario nel mirino
paventando perché vita la terza che sia
in veterinaria
federica ovvero giuro nel livorno per
parlare vitale
allora controlliamo le orecchie
berlina vuole mangiare la zucca con il
suo padroncino furono tutti a turno c'è
nella zucca di un mangione anche lui si
faccia
anche berlino vuole decorare la sua
zucca per halloween con i denti
che bello vendola biofesta preferita e
voi vi siete travestiti ovi travestire
da qualcosa per halloween scrivete nei
commenti ai nas ad un mi piace qua sotto
e se qualcuno ha bussato andiamo a
vedere ti ricordi anche l'anno scorso
per halloween bussato alla porta ed era
una zucca
sarà questa volta invece
[Musica]
chi è nessuno
un no che
cosa è quello è una zucca ma aspetta
meglio chiudere la folla è una di quelle
ciocche che si usano per fare dolcetto
scherzetto a millesimo scherno vie per
raccogliere le caramelle forse qualcuno
ci ha voluto regalare un po di caramelle
dolcetti non è per me
io sono a chimico del cibo devo subito
controllare tutto soprattutto perché ci
torneranno
bassi dobbiamo andare in giro a chiedere
dolcetto scherzetto così possiamo
prendere tutte le caramelline e poi io
le posso analizzare una ad una ma capri
la prima c'è qualcosa dentro
o no non ci sono per a melle
c'è un biglietto
non ci sono dubbi per me il profumato
sterlina meglio così almeno continua a
mangiare berlino continua a fare il
guardiano delle zucche vediamo
cosa dice se la prova volete superare a
dolcetto o scherzetto dovrete giocare
alla porta sbagliata non bussare
se la tua pelle vuoi salvare
non è una volta dovrete andare
finiti pronto a bussare scappare
se la prova non supererà i la
maledizione per sempre avrai che
maledizione da quanto ne so non abbiamo
nessuna maledizione almeno credo che
cos'è questo simbolo che vuol dire che
dobbiamo aprire le porte bussare alle
porte
dolcetto o scherzetto quindi dobbiamo
riempire il secchiello con dei dolci che
chiederemo in giro penso che intenda
alle porte qua fuori e penso che
dovremmo iniziare la challenge così
riusciremo a capirlo bene andiamo allora
io prendo la bacchetta e tu prendeva di
chiarirlo andiamo si sono pronto aspetta
un momento nel biglietto c'era scritto
solo una persona dovrà andare o no
giusto ci penso che non possiamo andare
insieme altrimenti non so cosa succederà
ma se già parla di una maledizione è
meglio non rischiare quindi chi va per
primo certo voi tu no non voglio andare
per prima non so cosa ci aspetta da
fuori vai tu
no io non voglio dare per primo devo
devo controllare bene secondo delle
caramelle per cercare di capire se
regolamentare questo cervello ok allora
facciamo carta forbice è stato per
vedere chi andrà per primo game ok va
bene ci sto
un round carata fornice forbice
o no
devi andare tu o vitto e va bene cosa
posso prendere per difendermi nel caso
prenderò il secchiello e questa per
farmi lucerna si così almeno riuscirò a
vedere meglio vediamo che cosa vi
aspetta tu vada a berlino ok va bene ok
tu stai attenta brown ok ok
meno male ci siete voi come almeno tu mi
piace questo atto per portarmi fortuna
sembra che anche berlino poteva venire
come mi proteggerà
andiamo
guardate c'è un simbolo su questa porta
cioè non un singolo o di immagini e
l'immagine
di un cestino che significa secondo cui
prima di scegliere la porta come diceva
il biglietto non scegliere la porta
sbagliata meglio che controllo di altre
immagini
c'è un'altra immagine
e un orologio che segna la mezzanotte
che cosa potrebbe esserci qua dietro
guardate c'è un'altra
melito
è un gelato sicuramente vitale vorrà
aprire questa porta perché c'è gelato
non so quale se vorrete 3 secondo poi
quali dovrei scegliere forse quella che
sembra che facciamo in paura e il
cestino non penso che ci sarà qualcosa
di troppo pauroso qua dietro sto in un
cestino al massimo potrebbe esserci
cappuccetto rosso è ok scelgo questa
porta
dolcetto o scherzetto
[Musica]
qualcuno
ecco perché cestino
va bene
che cosa è successo unità aspetta devo
portare questo
dietro ogni porta
se un personaggio come un personaggio e
che senso c'è un personaggio di quelli
paurosi un tipico personaggio pauroso
però tu non sai che personaggio ci sia
perché c'è solo un'immagine che ti dà un
indizio su chi c'è e una volta che aprì
la porta devi riuscire a scappare
velocissimamente dal personaggio non so
cosa succede se ti prende ti devi anche
dire dolcetto scherzetto è solo che non
mi ha dato nessun dolcetto quindi
immagino che il suo fosse uno scherzetto
inseguirmi e provare a mangiarmi forse
perché a me è capitato il lupo chiara
l'immagine del cestino pensavo fosse
cappuccetto rosso
no ovviamente capace però sta non fa
molta paura e nel lupo
ora tocca a testa è pronto non ci sono
sono pronto ad andare o no e vi per
forza completare la challenger
altrimenti avremmo con la maledizione
vero non ci avevo pensato
cole zhirkov solo l'uso qualsiasi porta
scegli l'importante che dopo ti prepari
a scappare velocissimamente a tornare
qua dentro ok prendi la mia bacchetta
per difenderti anche se non è una vera
bacchetta magica purtroppo
[Musica]
però puoi usarla per colpirle in testa
ok ok grazie devi chiedere dolcetto
scherzetto a quindi magari mi daranno
anche a qualche dolcetto non muove un po
allora questo ha detto devi pensare a
campare non è male questa challenge
secondo me magari sarò fortunato da
riempire il mio secchiello sperarci
troppo
forse è meglio se mi trovo questi
occhiali non vedo niente un orologio che
segna mezzogiorno terzo giorno qui
sicuramente si mangerà a mezzogiorno si
pranza giusto
mi sa che sceglierò questa prima voglio
vedere le altre magari c'è qualcosa di
meglio questa è la porta aperta infatti
alla porta con il cestino che diceva
anita quindi questa dovrebbe essere
sicura
vediamo qui c'è un'altra porta
qui ci sono due figure e credo siano due
bambini sembrano piccoli questa è la
porta giusta per me un gelato non vedo
l'ora di mangiar meno tutto e in più
posso anche chiedere dolcetto scherzetto
magari esce fuori anche qualche
caramella
dolcetto scherzetto
o dolcetto scherzetto
ma viene questo rumore
o no ciandri
rob dolcetto o scherzetto
no come no
ho paura che devo scappare dal rombo
si sta arrabbiato
ma
cosa stai facendo road
ciao
che è successo mamma mia me la sono
scampata per così poco c'è la rosa
dentro c'era le gelate ha detto cioè
sulla porta c'è l'ha disegnato un gelato
invece c'è la road ice scream hai capito
rob di certo che ho capito mi sorprende
che non ti ha congelato cioè surgelato e
trasformato in un gelato come quella
volta vi ricordate come hai fatto a
scappare ma del resto non lo so
ma qui c'è qualcosa
mi ha dato due caramelle ci posso
credere
beh io volevo il gelato però
effettivamente vanno bene anche delle
caramelle a kami per essere trasformate
funzionato e 6 con trento che ti ha dato
dalle caramelle ma certo non è mica
cattivo rob nel dato la caramelle o devi
essere surgelato ma tu sei solo gelosa
perché abbia votato le caramelle a terra
nessuno le ha date ora è meglio se mi
sbrigo solo un'altra porta vero no in
realtà c'è un'altra porta ed è subito
dopo quella che hai aperto to del lupo
quindi ce ne sono due ok è meglio che mi
sbrigo e vado queste caramelle forze con
me magari mi porteranno fortuna in
realtà è stato per non farle mangiare i
tratti a catania ma va bene le possiamo
dividere non ti preoccupare così anch'io
posso aggiungere le tue
che dici questo ci vediamo dopo ciao
stai attenta però
questa la porta che diceva vita
questa luce aperta ho già affrontato il
lupo quindi poi c'è un'altra porta
sono due sagome chi sono secondo voi tra
i cattivi
forse ho capito chi potrebbe essere
penso che sceglierò questa perché almeno
so chi potrebbe essere 10 con quella di
mezzanotte non ha idea di chi potrebbe
essere
dolcetto che effetto
[Musica]
cosa mi ha toccato i veti nei più che
maturi ed acqua
ecco mi è stato più facile di quello che
pensate davvero e ricevuto delle
caramelle non lo so se leo
si no queste sono quelle che è preso
tutta roba non c'era nessuno
praticamente ce l'ho sentito solo
qualcosa che mi sfiorava i piedi non
c'era nessuno stiamo potuta tornare qua
manca solo una porta quindi e tocca a me
quindi se ricordo bene e quella porta
molto facile dove c'era scritto
mezzogiorno 15 mezzogiorno
non so cos'abbia in mente e vitale si si
non ti preoccupare ci pensano
secondo voi se la caverà vitale se vi
piace questa challenge lasciate un mi
piace se questo mito e raggiunge i 10
mila mi piace sarà una seconda parte
delle morti misteriose sono pronta per
l'ordinanza vedo l'ora
dolcetto o scherzetto
speriamo sia un pranzetto
ricetto lo scherzetto
[Musica]
che è pronto
bevilaqua dai 24
grazie a uno scopo
sopportava ving cing anche delle
cartelle che entrò norvegia mezzanotte e
aspetta queste le tengo io intanto poi
li dividiamo dopo alla ragazzi tutto non
era mezzala nel mezzogiorno era
mezzanotte è come chi ha detto io
appunto c'era un grande ma certo il
cremlino mezzanotte ecco perché abbiamo
perso tutte le porte si del nostro
abbiamo superato la sales com'era
potrebbe continuare la nostra festa di
halloween certo io comincio a mangiare
una caramella intanto voi lasciate un
bel mi piace se volete vedere un altro e
solenne pauroso e ora vi lasciamo un pò
scavalca servirebbe quindi care per
vedere i vostri altri video le carte su
quella che preferite è una visione